مثل ما يحدث عاده في افلام الجاسوسيه او
العمل السري الاشهر 007 او مهما مستحيله
زينسكي يسافر الى واشنطن ويعود الى كيف
اجراءات غير عاديه تم اتخاذها لنقل الرئيس
الاوكراني الى العاصمه الامريكيه فتهديد
الصواريخ الروسيه تجعل السفر الجويه فوق
اوكرانيا محفوفا بالمخاطر الرحله انطلقت
ليلا عبر القطار الى بولندا صور من
التلفزيون البولندي اظهرت قطار اوكرانيا
باللونين الازرق والاصفر وبمحاذاته عدد من
المرافقين يسيرون على طول الرصيف بصحبه
زنسكي الذي ارتدى خلافا للبروتوكولات ستره
عسكريه خضراء وسروال عسكريا ثم دخلت
المجموعه في قافله من السيارات المنتظره
قبل ركوب طائره تابعه للقوه الامريكيه
اقلعت من مطار جيشوف على بعد حوالي 80 كلم
الى الغرب وقبل ان تدخل الطائره المجال
الجويه فوق بحر الشمال قامت طائره تجسس
تابعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي بمسح المنطقه اذ
من المعروف ان الغواصه الروسيه تحرص البحر
قبل ان ترافق رحله زينسكي في جزء منها
طائره مقاتله امريكيه من طراز اف 15 اقلعت
من قاعده في انجلترا طائره زينسكي اتجهت
الى الشمال الغربي نحو المملكه المتحده
ومن هناك اكمل الطريق الى الولايات
المتحده وبعد حوالي عشر ساعات من الاقلاع
هبطت الطائره بالقرب من واشنطن عند وصوله
حصلنسكي على حمايه الخدمه السريه كما هو
الحال مع جميع رؤساء الدول الزائرين لكن
مسؤوليه الامن كانوا اكثر يقظه وبعد ان
مرت زياره بثلاثه وبحلول الخميس قد عاد
بالفعل الى الارض الاوروبيه ونشر عبر
تيليجرام انه توقف في بولندا للقاء نظيره
اندري دودا ليكمل مغامراته الى كياف من
جديد
بلال الوجداني العربيه